so when I'm solving simultaneously uh
step two was not much of a step here is
step three what I'm going to end up
doing is saying hey if I'm equating
these right solving simultaneously
simultaneously is such a long word to
write but that's okay
I'm gonna do is I'm going to replace my
x's and y's and Z's with what I saw from
the equation of line PQ right so
therefore what I'm getting is something
like this let's try and draw it nice and
big so read the X components from line
PQ with me it's going to be 3 plus
one Lambda right so they're just Lambda
the y coordinate is going to be negative
1 plus 2 Lambda
and then the Z is negative 2 minus
Lambda
there we go
equals square root 26.
okay help me out what are we gonna do
with this
any suggestions for how I can do
something to help me work this out
probably
10 into like square root of paper yeah
you're very good
that's right so remember this this is a
magnitude right so the magnitude is just
using Pythagoras theorem in three
dimensions and because I've got a square
root on the right hand side and there's
going to be a square root on the left
hand side what I'm going to do is I'm
going to square out everything so I
don't have to worry about those right so
if you do like what you might remember
is this is our
formula for magnitude from the origin
right that's um that's going to be the
square root of 26 in this case right so
when I Square out both sides this is
what I'm going to get it's slightly
laborious but that's okay let's let's go
for it so there's my first one
three plus Lambda squared I've got
negative 1 plus 2 Lambda squared and
then lastly minus 2 minus Lambda squared
that is the square root of 26 squared
okay so that's why I get 26 over there
now this point uh you know hooray I have
some algebra to do right so you guys
probably can sort of leap ahead without
me in fact I'm guessing that's probably
what you're already doing what I'm going
to do is I'm going to try and keep up
with you a little bit I'm going to
expand everything out and what I'm going
to do slightly weird but I'm going to
write this expansion on the left hand
side across three lines and hopefully
you will see why I'm doing that right so
first binomial gives me this
9 plus 6 Lambda plus Lambda squared
next one's going to give me plus 1 minus
4 Lambda
plus 4 Lambda squared
and then what am I getting on the end
here this is going to be 4
plus 4 Lambda
plus Lambda squared
all of that is equal 226.
can anyone suggest to me why was it
worthwhile despite it being weird to
write this across three lines any
suggestions
yeah exactly I'm collecting like terms
right that's what I had to do out of
this monstrous expansion but really what
I'm doing is I'm setting up a vertical
algorithm like this is no different get
this right this is literally no
different to doing back when you were in
like year three or year four and you got
told if you were adding uh you know
three digit numbers together then what
you should do is you should put them in
a column right and you would do
something like this and then you would
you know off you go okay now this is
literally the same because when you see
like that see that five right there that
five is just code for five times ten
it's not really five right and then
what's that two it's code for two times
ten squared that's what base 10 means so
I've just replaced all my tens with
lambdas if you want to think about it
this way this is decimal base 10 and
what you're doing is arithmetic in base
Lambda I don't know if that makes you
feel better or worse for you but that's
what I'm doing I just want to make it
easy for me so what have I got uh let's
see here it looks to me like I'm getting
what 14
yeah the plus and minus four Lambda
cancel so that gives me six Lambda
and how many Lambda squares do I have
six also six that's all equal to 26 and
so if I subtract 26 from both sides and
tidy up just a little bit I'm going to
end up with
-12
what should we do with this
uh probably take that back from six yep
I'm gonna I'm gonna take out the factor
of six and then divide through by it
because I've got zero on the right hand
side anyway so that gives me Lambda
squared plus Lambda minus two uh this is
a nice easy quadratic to factorize what
are you guys getting
minus one okay outstanding so as we were
kind of hoping for I've got my two
values for Lambda they are negative two
and one so that that was probably the
hardest step that was the longest one
step three because step one wasn't too
difficult step two was hardly even a
step and we're now up to the final part
right what did we say we were going to
do with these lambdas
so I'm going to get uh some you know
coordinates from Lambda equals negative
two and then I'm going to get some
different coordinates from Lambda equals
one so let's call that two points A and
B for example right so if I call this a
and this Bay
uh maybe you guys can help me out here
right so I'm I might go back and get my
equation of my line here it is just so
that I can see it while I'm doing my
working
hopefully there we go I copied more than
I was supposed to there we go so so when
you substitute in can you see what I'm
doing here I'm going to get three plus
one because I've substitute Oh wrong one
sorry that's three uh minus two is that
right yeah
three minus two negative 1 minus four uh
negative two plus two how does that look
yeah yeah so here are my coordinates
just by simplification and then
correspondingly this is the one I
accidentally started working out this
one is three plus one
negative one plus two negative two minus
one
so we've got coordinates for this as
well
is that okay
three two
yeah I would ask you to have a look at
those coordinates and then do a sense
check for me right because even without
drawing it you could vary roughly like
um image in your mind where's the circle
where are these points and you could um
very roughly do this right but doing
sense checks in three dimensions it's
really hard right so what I'm going to
ask you to do is sorry I should have
asked this right at the start but is it
going to take you guys a while to open
up your laptops and boot them up do you
have them there
oh yeah you're on you're on the screen
of course you are okay so here's what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna try and do this
alongside
um you and it will take me some time so
don't worry Sean if you want to get your
laptop you'll have some time okay what I
want us to do is open up 3D geoge but
I'm going to try and do this at the same
time oh I just nope it just crashed
that's okay
there we go okay my
um my my iPad crash for a moments
hopefully you can still see that is that
coming up
yeah okay fantastic so uh I don't know
if you're able to I mean you can see
you're working in front of you and you
can also see um hopefully you're getting
jojoba up and running so I'm gonna have
to teach you just a little bit about how
to input this into geogebra but it's not
it's not too difficult okay
so what we want to do is put the sphere
on we want to put the line on and then
we want to see if the coordinates match
what we're hoping for right so to do
this part we are going to need like the
easiest way in 3D GE algebra is to do a
Cartesian equation okay so we did the uh
vector equation uh but I Ryan Sean I
couldn't quite hear which one of you
started talking about the Cartesian
equation and it's just going to use like
like a circle in two Dimensions instead
of x squared plus y squared what are we
going to add on to make it
three-dimensional
yeah that's right because that's what
we're calling our axes right so I'm
going to go ahead I'm going to go x
squared
plus y squared and you're like oh what
is this uh this is called a paraboloid
by the way you can do some I encourage
you to explore geogra in three
dimensions it's just there's so much
cool stuff you can do but if I add now a
z squared well not a square root a z
squared it's not giving me a sphere yet
because what's the missing piece I need
a radius now don't forget I'm about to
write a Cartesian equation right so
unlike the vector equation this is not r
on the right hand side it's
r squared very good because this is a
Pythagorean quadruple do you remember
we're talking about that so in this case
I won't write the square root of 26 I'll
just write
26. there we go okay so there's my
sphere sphere have you guys got one as
well
or you're just following me you don't
have to it's okay
that's okay all right all right so let's
now let's now add um let's now add a
circle onto this sorry we've got a
circle a sphere rather let's now add our
line so the equation of our line was
um you remember the position vector and
also the direction Vector so 3D geoge is
slightly finicky so I'm going to try and
do this right I tested out last night
so what I want is
um can you guys help me remember what
was the um what was the position vector
3 negative one negative two three
negative one
negative two okay so there is
um there is that now just pause for a
minute right can you see what's just
happened it's already put on
um a vector there that represents going
to the point three comma negative one
comma negative two but that's not what I
actually want right I don't want a
vector like that I want the the the
whole line that goes through this point
okay so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to add okay and tell me what was
the uh what was the direction Vector we
worked out we simplified it didn't we
one two negative one two and then
negative one and then to turn this into
the line that we want I hope I get this
right because I was testing it before
I'm going to multiply by uh a an
appropriate what's it called
um an appropriate parameter that's what
we call Lambda right now it tends to be
I think what GE algebra is expecting is
a t yay success I got it okay so have a
look what do we got here
this is and I might just actually put
um three uh what was it three negative 1
negative two that was our position
Vector right sorry there we go
three comma negative one comma negative
two there it is okay
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
spin this around now so you can see sure
enough that line that we just created
line PQ right
um in fact let's let's call that P
because that is what it was
all right
shift p there we go right okay here's P
it is on the line right I suppose we
could put Q as well if you wanted to be
sure but hopefully you're convinced that
that is the right line and as you can
see it it does intersect with the sphere
at a couple of spots okay so finally
we're ready to actually test did we get
the spots right okay so can you tell me
what are the coordinates of the first
point we found
one negative
five and zero so I'm going to hold my
breath and then can you give me the
second point
4 1 and negative three four one negative
three and I cannot tell you what a sigh
of relief I gave when I put this into 3D
geogebra and I I thought oh I got it
right you can even see because it's on
the outside of the sphere if I zoom in a
little bit there you can see it's not um
compare compare A and P can you see p is
actually inside the sphere and that's
why it's kind of um it's a bit
translucent in front the Reds in front
of it right whereas a you can see pops
out in front and B if you look really
closely at it you can see it's also
popping out as well and it's a bit
different I've just rotated around so
now a is behind right it's on the other
side but there you go okay so
um I encourage you when you're doing
these questions in three dimensions make
use of 3D geogebra so you can see what's
going on because you want to visualize
it but it is just as you can tell
extraordinarily hard to draw right so I
use technology to help you there that's
that's why it's there okay
all right does anyone have any questions
does that make sense
that's cool
okay brilliant
um and hopefully by the way you can
start to think even though I haven't
really talked about it explicitly just
how important these applications are to
just like engineering and Communications
in the world like we do things like this
all the time a lot of the calculations
that are going on underneath say for
example the global positioning system
GPS when satellites are trying to work
out where you are
um they do these calculations all the
time in three-dimensional vectors it's
um it's really phenomenal that we're
touching such a very relevant practical
piece of math